so in this video I want to show you some
simple things you can do to slow down
the aging process now some of the
information I'm gonna talk about in this
video is out of this book right here I'm
gonna break it down really simply but
it's this book is called
oxidants in biology fascinating read you
need a medical dictionary to get through
it because there's a lot of biochemistry
but there's some gold nuggets in this
book okay and they're talking about the
balance between antioxidants and
oxidants okay in the environment so you
have this constant battle because if
you're being exposed to all this
oxidation you can kind of compare this
to a car rusting out I mean it's kind of
weird that oxygen would create damage
but too much of it can be very very
damaging to your cells okay the
mitochondria which is at the heart of
your metabolism it's the energy Factory
and it actually has an engine and uses
oxygen to break down fuel so it actually
releases oxidants okay now some of that
is good for the body in that these
oxidants that your body makes kills off
microbes but when the mitochondria and
other parts of the cell become damaged
and you're getting too much oxidation
from that that can actually destroy the
cell and create all sorts of problems
and set you up for even getting cancer
so there's a positive part of oxidation
and there's a negative part and the same
thing goes with antioxidants which
counter the oxidation you can get
antioxidants from food and your body can
make antioxidants and that is called
endogenous antioxidants this means
antioxidants that are made within your
body as compared to exogenous
antioxidants which are antioxidants
outside the body okay so from vegetables
for example but a really really
important and misunderstood area is
building up your antioxidant Network and
getting your body to make more
antioxidants so I'm going to show you
just a few things you can do to build up
this network without taking external
antioxidants the hormone called
melatonin is a very powerful antioxidant
okay this occurs when you're sleeping so
when it gets dark and the
less light coming into the eye there's
an entire cascade of things that happen
in your brain and one is you get a spike
of melatonin melatonin actually gets rid
of hydrogen peroxide maybe you have used
hydrogen peroxide in the past let's say
you had a cut and you want to sterilize
it to kill the bacteria you you put the
hydrogen peroxide and it bubbles up and
it kills off the microbes well your
cells actually make hydrogen peroxide to
kill off microbes as well but sometimes
our bodies make too much hydrogen
peroxide and that's very toxic to the
body because it's creating too much
oxidation well if you have enough
melatonin this can counter that and
that's just one thing that it does but I
don't recommend going to the store and
buying melatonin what I am gonna
recommend is just getting more sleep or
take naps okay so the second thing that
they talk about in here is the
difference between occasional exercise
and regular exercise regular exercise as
in routine in on a regular basis will
build up your endogenous antioxidant
Network okay
now initially when you do exercise let's
say it's an intense workout you're gonna
generate tremendous amounts of oxidation
it's gonna break down the muscle tissue
let's consider bad right but as you do
it over time your body gets used to it
it starts to adapt and it starts to
build up huge amounts of antioxidants to
counter the stress or oxidation damage
from exercise so regular exercise on a
consistent basis will help to build up
your antioxidants and protect you
against oxidation and you are going to
start looking younger when you do this
and it could be as simple as walking
every day but routine regular exercise
is very very important so we have high
quality regular sleep or naps and
regular exercise it seems really really
simple next one is fasting and I'm
talking about regular fasting as in
intermittent fasting because you can't
just do fasting on a long-term basis
because at some point you have to eat
right but intamin fasting would be a
regular
routine of combination of fasting and
eating and that produces huge spike in
your endogenous antioxidant Network an
ideal pattern for you to work up to
would be 20 hours of fasting in a 4-hour
eating window so let's say for example
you a tab 3 and then the next meal would
be at 4 5 6 and 7 ok so it would be 4
hours later that would be like the
eating window but then you'd fast for 20
hours that would be very very beneficial
if you're new to my channel I put a link
below of how to do that the benefit of
fasting is something called autophagy
autophagy means self eating so your body
is actually recycling its own tissue one
of the bad effects from oxidation that
causes aging or premature aging is what
oxidation does to your proteins okay it
creates what's called miss folded
proteins and these proteins kind of gunk
up and they get stuck in the body they
don't exit the body that well and they
clog up things between your neurons
creating memory problems and eventually
Alzheimer's they clog up the heart and
they're in the eye they're in the kidney
they're in the nervous system so there's
miss folder proteins come from oxidation
and also they actually create oxidation
they create a toxic effect in the body
and your body has a hard time getting
rid of these because they're
non-functional well it just so happens
that fasting through autophagy can take
these miss folder proteins
put them into a garbage disposal and
start to break down these proteins okay
there's actually detergents that your
body uses in certain enzymes to break
down this protein and on the other side
it spits out brand-new amino acids that
your body can then use to rebuild so
fasting really slows down the aging
process as well as stimulate certain
genes that help
so here we have sleeping or napping
regular exercise and intimate of fasting
these three are very very very powerful
and that's why I want to put your
attention on this okay
the next thing to do is to avoid
excessive amount of oxidants now a body
makes enough oxidants for us to then get
more externally iron for example like
let's say for example you're taking a
multi supplement from the drugstore read
the label make sure it doesn't have iron
in it because that's one way to get the
wrong type of iron
the thing about iron is it's very
difficult to get rid of iron if there's
too much so you want to avoid cooking
and iron skillets for example and
definitely don't take iron as a
supplement unless you have for example
some anemia which you're low in iron and
you tested it in which case you can take
a food base iron which comes from like
bovine liver make sure it's grass-fed
and of course one of the biggest things
that creates oxidation is high levels of
sugar in the diet even your blood
Sugar's being high that will just
oxidate the the eyes kidney the nerves
the brain so this is a real big one
right here glycation what is that that
is the combination between sugar and a
protein so if you're eating foods that
are cooked with sugar and protein that's
really really bad or you're consuming
foods with fat and sugar together heated
that would be very very bad that creates
some serious oxidation so that would be
like ice cream for example because
you're cooking in this fat with this
sugar you're gonna get a lot of
glycation and glycation also happens in
our bodies if you have high levels of
blood sugar and your body is 98.6 it can
actually create glycation of your your
red blood cells and one of the tests for
that which is related to diabetes is
called a1c that's glycation of the
protein in your blood so you want to
reduce the glycation simply by knocking
out this sugar okay and then vegetable
oils especially the corn and the soy oil
very high in omega-6 creates a lot of
oxidation
frequent meals will increase oxidation
thus the intermittent fasting so let's
say for example you join the gym right
and they have this CrossFit class and
they're working out every single day and
year fifty-five years old very bad
you're gonna over train it's too much
exercise without much recovery it's
gonna create a lot of oxidation and then
we have cortisol having too much your
cortisol over a period of time without
enough recovery is really bad this has
to do a stress also if you're taking
prednisone or a cortisol or any
medication that can create some massive
damage and the damage is creating is
oxidation so stress in general creates a
lot of oxidation on your body but if
you're getting regular exercise and good
sleep you can easily counter the stress
of life but you need to look at the big
picture and really look at the balance
of these two okay we want to build up
your endogenous antioxidant Network and
of course we have trans fats you want to
avoid those and then there's a lot of
other things avoiding chemicals
pesticides GMO foods all of that creates
oxidation and the last thing I'm going
to just touch on is exogenous
antioxidants raw vegetables cruciferous
usually you want to steam some of your
cruciferous but then have your salads
raw and that's part of the photo
nutrients in cruciferous which give
additional health benefits that go
beyond just vitamins and minerals
alright guys so that was your tip of the
day the next step is for you to go ahead
and implement this
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos